guillaume et personne n'est venu ce soir
car elle a quelque chose à te dire on va
commencer par un premier indice d'un
inconnu regarde
il pense qu'une première fois peut-être
vécu une deuxième fois
au reçues qu'une première fois peut-être
vécu une deuxième fois le père fouras
c'est quelqu'un à qui j'ai fait chaud
on va écouter sa voix est ce que cette
voie vous pas
ma voix
la voix
on n'a pas le soir que ni la voix tu
m'entends la voix on l'a vu il ya quinze
jours ils l'ont pas très bon mais je dis
que des jeunes il ya un continuer sur
cette route sur ce chemin pour vous
aider outre un troisième indice est une
photo place regarde
à wassit chevaux
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
mais
c'est vraiment à gérer ma nage qu'est ce
que tu connais au montage toi à
guillaume et qu'est ce que tu connais au
démontage remontage
c'est comme ça la chaise est ce qu'on
connaît cette photo il sort les gens ne
subisse
connaissez cette jeune fille samedi
quelque chose mais je
[Rires]
n'aime pas ce que vous voulez voir cette
personne
regardez elle a quelque chose à vous
dire regardez de cette idée regardez
regardez
soir va changer bonsoir
n'étant pas ça
je dirais oui
je ne vois pas où tu dis que je me bats
pas quelqu'un ne pas ouvrir laurino tu
vois très bien et je vais ouvrir le
rideau dans la bonne humeur
jean bédard
[Applaudissements]
je
non gilles bonnet judy in situ dans la
classe de guillaume g t au primaire avec
lumières à strass voix c'est vraiment
très bien ça date c'est vrai je lis très
moche comment
mélanger samedi quelque chose n'importe
laquelle des mois ouais on devrait ouais
bah je crois dans le cochon ça me dit
quelque chose moi je me souviens très
bien de toi tu avais été petite chemise
à fleurs ou tapis car l'autre oui non
mais eux ils étaient déjà
deux mois on m'appelait carlos que je
ressemblais le chanteur j'avais déjà
prévu la faute au temps pas
vraiment mignon ce que vous êtes
célibataire aujourd'hui ah oui oui
guillaume est ce que tu es célibataire
aujourd'hui alors pas
malheureusement non mais bon non ah bah
oui je suis célibataire
la ligue américaine
dès ce soir même et ce soir oui moi je
suis au repos ni pts et 10
alors allez-y allez-vous parler tout
seul ici
[Applaudissements]